in this market environment the very
mention of one economic term sets the
big indexes on edge but at this point
the economy is very strong and
inflationary pressures are high and and
it is therefore appropriate in my view
to consider wrapping up the paper of our
asset purchases which we actually
announced at the november meeting
perhaps a few months sooner that's the
chairman of the federal reserve in late
november foreshadowing that the central
bank would speed up tapering or winding
down of the bond buying program it
launched in 2020 to help fight the kova
19 economic crisis
his words sent a shutter through the
markets
papering tapering paper they should be
tapering and it's easy to see why the
fed's stimulus has fueled a historic
rally that has lifted major indexes far
beyond their pre-pandemic highs so if
the economy is strong as powell said and
stimulus has been so good for stock
portfolios why are the markets so
worried
here's jerome powell again this time in
july of 2020 amid pandemic shutdowns
that had ground the global economy to a
halt at the federal reserve we remain
committed to using our tools to do what
we can and for as long as it takes
to provide some relief and stability he
was promising in part to continue
purchasing 80 billion dollars of
treasury bonds and 40 billion dollars of
mortgage-backed securities every month
to increase the money supply encourage
lending and help bring the economy back
from the brink this type of stimulus is
called quantitative easing and it works
like this
when the fed buys securities on the open
market it takes them out of circulation
leaving fewer for everyone else to
compete for with less supply investors
bid up the price of the remaining
securities and as is always the case
with bonds when the price goes up the
yield goes down
so what does it mean for you since
treasuries are a benchmark for other
types of lending lower yields on
long-term treasury bonds can mean
cheaper corporate bonds and mortgages
which can lead to more hiring and home
buying throughout the economy this helps
explain why markets thrive on
quantitative easing and why they get
jittery at the mention of tapering but
there are a few things to keep in mind
first tapering refers to winding down
the rate at which the fed adds to its
balance sheet not actually reducing the
total holdings the current plan is to
reduce purchases by 30 billion dollars a
month to end in march
during this period the fed's balance
sheet will keep growing just more slowly
second winding down the stimulus puts
the fed in a position to focus on
another of its imperatives price
stability here's the former secretary of
the treasury larry summers talking to
the wall street journal's greg ipp
we're now
running
with inflation in the five six percent
uh
range
and
achieving a soft landing from that
without recession i think is not likely
to be easy inflation rose to 6.8 in
november from a year earlier the fastest
pace since 1982. a year and a half of
stimulus has driven a rise in household
income spurring a sharp run-up in home
values and other assets this has boosted
wealth for many americans fueling
stronger demand meanwhile a tight labor
market and lasting supply chain issues
has restricted supply leading many
businesses to raise prices this is the
big reason powell is talking about
speeding up the taper the sooner the fed
completes the wind down the sooner it
would be able to focus on bringing
inflation back down to its two percent
target we are committed to our price
stability goal
we will use our tools both to support
the economy and a strong labor market
and to prevent higher inflation from
becoming entrenched
on wednesday fed officials signaled they
were prepared to raise interest rates
next year to help bring down high
inflation and some more hawkish
economists see a bumpy road ahead i
think we've got a very difficult set of
policy management challenges ahead of us
with a period of entrenched inflation
looking like the immediate prospect but
for all the fed's preparations powell
says it still expects inflation could
retreat on its own most forecasters
including at the fed continue to expect
that inflation will move down
significantly over the next year as
supply and demand imbalances abate
with an uncertain road ahead the markets
will continue watching the fed for any
sudden moves
[Music]